Rock China versus Rob Kardashian episode
for a new hope plus my exclusive with
Abby Lee Miller just days before she
enters a federal prison and we've got
some MTV nostalgia for you today Teen
Wolf is back and maybe Jersey Shore
Cambria I want my MTV I friends this is
the daily Denny I'm Denny direct oh and
there is not enough coffee in the world
today and you're going to need it too as
we entered this next chapter of the Rob
and Chyna saga like many of you we've
been following these too closely who
have been at each other's throats for
weeks and today it was in a courtroom
Chyna was granted a temporary
restraining order against Rob which
means he must stay away at least 100
yards from his ex he's also not allowed
to post any pictures of her or their
daughter dream the judge also said that
Rob and Chyna would continue to share
custody of dreams now this is all after
Rob went off on social media accusing
Chyna of cheating and posting what
appeared to be private nude photos of
her online and while that could land him
in even more legal trouble Rob has not
yet been charged with the crime
Rob did not appear in court today but et
was on the scene as Chyna arrived with
her attorneys by her side Chyna also
broke her silence on Monday following
the intense social media blowout between
her and her ex during an interview on
Good Morning America I was devastated of
course I'm like how could somebody like
post these pictures of me and I'm like
like whoa okay like this is a person
that I trusted I just felt betrayed yeah
betrayed Chyna also addressed her
actions and why she sent Rob a video of
her kissing another man she says if
someone's going to keep poking you
eventually you pop she thought if she
sent him the video he would leave her
alone we have yet to hear from the
Kardashians on the matter but when that
happens we've officially got episode 5
the Empire Strikes Back meanwhile
Chyna's BFF Amber Rose is also sharing
pictures in bed with a man only they are
fully clothed and the man is new
boyfriend rapper 21 savage and clearly
she is head over heels because in the
heartfelt caption she wrote I've
cried endlessly and been hurt a lot in
my life so I'm thankful that God brought
this amazing person in my life who
genuinely has my back
good on you amber looks like she finally
put her love on top folks see what I did
there how to sneak her in alright moving
on to Dance Moms star Abby Lee Miller on
Wednesday she will turn herself into a
federal prison to begin a one year and
one day sentence for defrauding the
government out of seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in a bankruptcy
case now you would think she would be
lying low right now but I can tell you
firsthand that is not the case I caught
up with Abby at the Marvel Universe live
from here over the weekend about how she
will be spending her last days of
freedom I just want to kind of enjoy
some laughter and some fun I have some
friends coming out from Pittsburgh that
has been listening through thick and
thin and for 20 years before TV show so
they're going to come out and we're just
going to reminisce and laugh about the
old times we'll be joining in and talk
about everyone we know and who might
have all that money this is not me not
you um who's going with you when you do
check-ins present life time I believe
okay cameras will be rolling right why
was important for you to kind of like
let the cameras come with you it wasn't
it wasn't important to me it was
important to them really yes you regret
that they're showing up you wish you
could fight it I signed a four-year
contract with a four-year option and
yeah my signatures actually on that you
look amazing I mean how's life after a
surgery yeah ah good you know my eyes
and my brain are definitely still
ordering off a menu like they used to
you concerned about keeping the weight
off in prison no I'll just me to
concentrate on and that's different I've
always put everybody else's child first
before my own health so I think this
will be a little me time
finally we'll be seeking dance in prison
come on I might be really I don't know I
don't really know as you guys can tell
Abby was surprisingly a beat when I
chatted with her I did not get the sense
at all that this woman was nervous about
going to prison I mean you heard her
refer to her sentence as me time like
she's checking into a spa she even joked
about her biggest prison concern is
whether they will find a bra that fits
her right you can't make this stuff up
both
I'm moving right along I have a
confession to make because I've been
sleeping on MTV for a minute or two but
this summer the former teen tastemaker
has me grabbing for a backpack and a
juice box because the nostalgia is real
first of all there's a trailer for the
final ten episodes of Teen Wolf the
whole pack is back including Tyler
hoechlin Colton Haynes and Dylan O'Brien
check it out
you think you're doing this without me
did you without us
[Music]
welcome back you must all be feeling
rather right yes and then as if that
weren't enough there's this very sunny
teaser for a new show that is being
touted as the new hill and Laguna Beach
it's called siesta key and it takes
place in Sarasota County Florida and now
we get to see if the beach action is as
hot on the East Coast as it was on the
west all I know is you may be pretty
Florida but you're going to have to go
long and fortify so net specialist
Spencer Pratt so I'm going to say
and finally the ladies of Jersey Shore
are living their best adult lives
reunited and hanging out well on the
Jersey Shore check out this picture of
Snooki JWoww Sammi Sweetheart and Deana
and Point Pleasant in the dirty Jers
having dinner and drinks and plain
boardwalk games
apparently the girls have been shooting
something with a project named roadtrip
reunion and although it's reportedly not
a project for MTV I am here for it no
matter what and I'm still waiting for
Sammi and Ronnie to get back together
and it will happen eventually
Ron ah by the way if MTV is playing on
bringing back TRL I got your host right
here you know I can dance I look pretty
good on camera what else do you need
alright I'm just kidding you guys
because I love this gig too much and I
hope you guys do too be sure to
subscribe to et's youtube channel so you
don't miss an episode of The Daily denne
like comment share I do want to hear
from you guys and as always stick with
each online.com for the latest on Robin
China and all things entertainment
thanks for watching you guys I'm going
to dance my way out of here you know the
deal